forty-eight seconds of logos I had a
vision in a medieval you may remember it
it was basically a trailer for this
movie I had a premonition of your desk
previously on checks notes the a
medieval conjuring or maybe this is
Annabel forever I really can't keep up
anymore
that looks like crackhead Bonnie found
the Lord good for her I always wondered
what happened to her after the fighter
so II you couldn't just put 1952 on the
screen like every other asshole does
what's what the complete sentences just
making sure we got enough crosses for
you you mean for the hallway scene no I
want so many crosses the sisters won't
even be able to walk down the hallway
without having to inconveniently shimmy
sham around them let's have a bunch
hanging from the ceiling as well and
twelve thawed machines turn to the Mack
Sennett we're gonna horror cliche this
up right in the right decision we have
no other choice except do you totally do
you could jump on the next bus out of
st. Carter and not look back look horror
movies got to work who the relic Trudy
save us
damn how bad must your faith be if
you're relying on a Peter Hyams movie
forty-five years into the future to save
you are you hoping the time cop is real
a little crash to 1952 like a sound of
thunder before the end of days and your
sudden death stay tuned because I have a
feeling that won't happen until 2010 and
even then by a narrow margin
the problem with stuff like this is you
have no idea what this nun did to get
the key in the first place why the evil
presence allowed her to get this far
and give instructions to her buddy
before it decides to yank her back into
the evil room not even let's retire this
jumpscared from all wait does God work
like some sort of benevolent Minority
Report where you can ask forgiveness
before you commit a sin hello absolution
crime tour twenty nineteen baby also
does sister Victoria really have to kill
herself once she dies the demon has no
power to leave the ADI so why wouldn't a
simple escape work why not have a bunch
of mattresses waiting on the steps and
jump to safety with the key and get the
hell out of Dodge
also also this key opens up a secret
room with a glorified snow globe full of
Jesus Christ's blood in it maybe she
should have left some instructions on
the back story instead this is going to
require a psychic girl to figure it out
while valance with whomever the Vatican
sends to solve the mystery sure move
slowly it's not like she's got a rope
around her neck and about the jump but I
have no clue that even matters because
all I've seen so far is a couple of nuns
that make poor decisions and a key
enter shut the window why not just do
that before the sister jumped man this
body sure has amazing dramatic time
since it is a choice to convent and your
access will be limited but aren't you
the Vatican you tell them to give this
guy all the access in case you confused
it with London Ohio which according to
my records is a thing my only hope now
is that the Beast could not smell me but
then the wind change this chick is
Belling so hard here it almost feels
like they just took the Beauty and the
Beast setup and threw a nun in the
castle instead of a beast also holy they
digitally young and virile Farmiga wait
a minute this is her much younger sister
but by the end of this movie she has no
connection to Lorraine Warren unless
they're going to soap opera this thing
and tell us that she is Lorraine Warren
and she used to be a nun and she got
amnesia exercising too talking tika
hey-oh a periodic tables in 1952 only
recognized 13 elements of course this is
a Catholic school so they might have
considered stuff like carbon and
hydrogen sinful and don't even get me
started on sodium the bible is god's
love letter to us i'm a fan of my love
letters being filled with brutal
killings and incest so good to know that
this was the intention all along I've
never been in that part of the world
there must have been some mistake every
decision that Vatican makes is with
purpose there is a purpose but why would
they lie about Irene having experience
in Romania and isn't liason lying is a
sin ah sudden shining blood stares not
my friends you're in the Dark Ages the
joke is that they think Frenchy drives
the struck so they put their suitcases
on the back of it and then the truck
drives off and reveals that Frenchy
actually drives this horse-drawn
carriage Hey look I know we can't see
where this guy went but they sure as
hell could so I'm having trouble buying
that and who makes this kind of
assumption without asking the driver if
that's his vehicle or not I guess
instinctively the truck driver knows
this whistle was meant for him the
postman charged well there is a clue on
this crossword that is 10 letters with
an L that goes across father Burke is
clearly pointing at a word that is going
down and does not fit the parameters the
lowest won't go any further locals say
it's the cursed place when the host
agrees so when we were first introduced
to Frenchy
he was merrily riding his horse toward
the Abbey to deliver produce and while
we never saw the horse anywhere near him
during that scene I'm pretty sure they
made this we have to walk part up just
for this whether the movie was lying to
us or not about the horse how could he
have gotten the cart full of supplies
over this bridge you see this Kirk how
is that getting over this at the very
least his pants and shoes would be wet
from crossing the street right not to
mention the difficult
of carrying that thing through the
obstacle course of crosses before he
even got to the bridge and I found the
sister I thought maybe moving her in
here would help Reserva
wait what the sister's body is still
there so the authorities took the time
to contact the Vatican but didn't move
the body to the morgue or conduct an
investigation that's yeah spooky but
what the demon do that for any reason
whatsoever in cases bodies twitching or
not there have been a lot of cases of
bodies bla bla bla after death cliche
yeah but father who knows how long she
was that when I found her
you're not helping wouldn't say you are
either father with your weird ass dead
bodies can sit up by themselves theory
you should give her a proper burial
they haven't even checked the convent to
see if there are any other nuns around
or if maybe one of them wants to join
them in putting their sister to rest the
character logic it's maddening even for
horror movie I'm pretty sure that over
the first 20 minutes of this film half
of it has been characters carrying
luggage and no one has cleaned this up
seriously how do they believe for a
second the second place is inhabited by
anything other than demon nuns hope you
like slow walking and steering because
that's pretty much the rest of this
movie are you the Reverend Mother you
know that it's a demon right this is
supposed to be the one thing you're good
at the Vatican means to vet it's
supernatural and force her applicants a
little better in the future I'm afraid
that won't suffice
it will just send more and perhaps less
diplomatic Georgia officials now the
father Burke realizes the nuns didn't
even know the sister was missing much
less dead why is he waiting to have
reinforcements brought in this place
probably needs to be shut down it's
pretty clear this isn't a safe work
environment that is lodging in the
convent
you may stay there why not just kill
these people now demons and their
timetables that just start with random
curry I know poltergeist is a great
movie but god damn you poltergeist let
me find some good luck in a few days I
should give us enough time what we need
but no reason to be more specific about
your time frame Frenchy is just your
only way out of this place
it's not like he's important or anything
also nine of these nuns get their food
delivered but what if they need to get
somewhere like a hospital not like they
can hail a cab
I'm sure these types of places exist but
there has to be some sort of
transportation for getting out as well
as getting it this ghost nun goes
through a ton of to set up what amounts
to a jump scare she shows up here and
walks away tears again dragging a noose
behind her and nearly a full minute
later recreates a hanging complete with
the Rope breaking and going in for a
scary at fruitless attack after one last
foggy scare pearance the nun disappears
I've never had
fun jerking off to a scene in my life
tag you're it for a movie called the nun
I'm seeing a lot of demonic but not
really seeing the nun and she's scary
she's what this movie was sold on and of
course she's in the room with the
picture of sister Charlotte from
Annabelle - Easter eggs are fun and
alone but this just reminds me of a much
better movie that I would much rather be
watching though you mentioned miracle
hunting before is that a role you saw I
know originally I wanted to be a
crossword champion but you can clearly
see I suck fatso miracle hunting it was
while this crossword puzzle now has
deliveries written in after Irene
answered the ten letter clue with an L
this is in no way the same puzzle he was
working on also the clue for deliveries
is simply transfer old and nothing
involving the postman I guess it could
be a new crossword from a completely
different paper and it's a coincidence
but I had a serious efficience when I
was a girl of course you did I would
take us in off if one of these
supernatural movies didn't have a
character with visions this is probably
the first point addressed in lazy
screenplay writing one on one can't
figure out how to explain what a demon
wants no problem throw a character who
sees in the mix and they can exposition
away but one of my visions reach the
church Cardinal Conroy specifically and
he sent Bishop for him to meet with me
why didn't the Vatican just tell father
Burke they were sending a woman who has
visions with him rather than the whole
she knows Romania story maybe he
wouldn't believe them but they are the
Vatican right the hell they care if you
believe them or not after each one ended
the same thought would be stuck in my
head Mary points the way so each of your
visions which you just said we're all
different gave you the same message
which ties directly into this very
specific mission later in the movie or
do you spend your remaining days on
earth finding Mary statues pointing at
key places all around the world god
damned demons always pick the Jazz
Channel also I've seen this horror trope
so many times now that I bet you could
make a 5 CD collection called horror
cliche rock complete with a minute long
commercial of scrolling songs filled
with stuff like jeepers creepers tiptoe
through the tulips and so much more also
I'm a demonic presence that could do
anything I want should I just ripped the
throats out of father Burke and sister
Irene when they sleep and be done with
them man I'll turn on this radio and
make them wonder how it happened that
seems like way more fun don't mind me
Father I'm just trying to find a men's
bathroom in this convent damn it
possible inexplicable section of the
convent full of bedsheets hanging from
the ceiling
tag Europe Parseltongue also I thought
this movie was called the nun not the
boy or whatever this kid is why does the
demon bother throwing father Burke into
an open grave and bury him completely
under magically appearing ground even
picking out a personalized tombstone
only to put him in the grave with one of
those I'm alive Belle's so that someone
can save him just do something for once
this is what happens not too long after
your vows of celibacy so she heard the
bell ring and she's gonna save father
Burke awesome my question is why she
even out here she felt the breeze and
this led to her walking outside to find
Burke how exactly sure this is an
effective way of making sure that no one
can figure out which greatest father
Burke's but then you could have simply
not provided a tombstone that read hero
his father Burt or decline to put a bell
on it in the first place
I know people are genuinely frightened
of stuff like this but afterwards father
Burke won't be injured dead or
psychologically change from this
experience these scares are
biochemically no different than eating
large quantities of chocolate to quote
my favorite Satan I mean those books
will help shine a light on our ass or
you could and I'm just spitballing here
get the out of there also so you mean
the evil presence threw you into an open
grave that it knew you might escape and
there just happened to be a coffin with
all these Handy books lying around in
said grave once you were free by the way
none of this was in your coffin while
you were ringing the bell and getting
strangled by discount Brad door there's
more of it how is that possible another
possible it's a really stupid puzzle
though and it's yet another puzzle that
goes unsolved in this movie and I'm sure
an Annabelle witchdoctor double Christ
will find out that the extra blood is
from Elise Rayner when she's time-travel
ghost hunting in the extended further
universe also his sister Irene just not
going to share her experiences the
previous night with disappearing nuns
and broken mirrors that might be
relevant before they go back to the
convent because I guess the slaughtered
lamb was taken why did I because
something's cropped unto dust
well the fan struck blind another giant
failing of the movie is that the
surrounding town is being affected by
the evil presence at the Abbey but all
of it is told to a second hand by some
bartender we don't know any of these
characters he's talking about or care
about this town at all thereby reducing
the impact of this demons presence can
you tell me about the history of this
Abbey it was built by a Duke he wrote
countless texts on witchcraft and rich
in which to call upon the forces of
health and now we go at home he sealed
the Gateway using an ancient relic
containing the blood of Jesus Christ we
put in a bid on ebay and we stuck it to
the southern baptists once and for all
and look at this it's a certificate of
authenticity so I invited hoping himself
evil was kept at bay until the bombs of
war shook the abbey and evil found
another way to open the gateway oh come
on if it was this easy for demons to
spring out of the ground they do it
every time there was an earthquake or
something the Archduke who built this
place should have just grabbed a shovel
and dug for a really long time rather
than building an entire Castle complete
with a sealed floor that required black
magic for a demon to burst through also
what kind of target is an abbey out in
the middle of nowhere in Romania it
takes on different forms to deceive us
and prey on our weaknesses this nun
talking to Irene is just a vision that
died long ago
but the ultimate confusion in this movie
is whether VALIC is responsible for this
vision or if Irene is it makes a little
sense that VALIC would provide visions
of helpful nuns to tell Irene important
things to help her beat him but it's
even more puzzling that Irene wouldn't
recognize these nuns as visions unless
VALIC was responsible for them after
admittedly just a vision sister Ilana
told us about the nun being sneaky
becoming whatever forms she wants as a
means to an uncertain end how does this
factor into the plan when you analyze
the jumpscares in this movie they only
serve the audience and not one bit of
the story Freddy Krueger might as well
show up totally weird to wake up and see
a person in your room that wasn't there
before but what's even weirder is
sleeping with the shoes still on also
sudden months crosses turning X Kippen
this would be a hundred percent more
effective and maybe even scary if we
knew how Irene got to this point of
discovery there may be a little bit
about what the nun is trying to
accomplish there are literally no king
stakes in this movie
other than Irene and Burke my daughter
and I'm not even sure if I care at this
point whether or not that happens
Jesus why did the nun even shut the door
in the first place she had the key to
the relic in her grasp what was
preventing her from getting it now I'm
totally confused
it's the nun confined behind this door
or not at one point she's all over the
convent spreading her evil at another
she's blocked by a door can't even steal
a key Eva ha strong rumor has it that
the evil can now do 665 squats on morale
get your things and
only prayer will get us through the
night but make sure you get your things
can't pray without your things father
Burke is one of those characters in
movies that is propped up as one of the
movies heroes but nothing he's done
makes us think that he'll have the
answer in the end here he is in
cautiously chasing after a mysterious
nun into a confessional shortly after
being attacked not to mention being
buried alive and his lack of awareness
is stunning
also if the nun you chase was in there
what was the plan once the curtains are
opened are you gonna say boo and play it
all off as a joke movie so you're
looking to join a church here are five
warning signs sister while this dead nun
is just a vision it does remind us that
the demon killed all the nuns before
Irene and Burke got here but it's having
a devil of a time killing them for some
reason dude last time you did this you
wind it up in a coffin ringing a bell
and getting attacked by I don't know
Evan ease our Scrooge but one who didn't
pay attention to the ghost of Christmas
timelines yeah these are Scrooge showed
up in this movie I don't remember why
what does VALIC send game here using
Daniel to freak out father Burke serves
zero purpose in horror movie theory it
does because the demon is trying to
weaken its human subject through
psychological curry but I'm beginning to
think horror movies need to start
putting a threat level meter on the
screen that shows us the demons progress
so that we know when to be upset about
it don't you think we should have the
nun actually do something to these
people nah man having her just stare at
them would be way scarier I especially
think the demon is changing this
crossword puzzle now because this is the
third iteration of it let's go back to
the last time we saw it father Burke had
answered one of the clues Legman for a
reporter in action but now that answer
is gone he had answered taxi for part of
the city fleet and that's gone and
deliveries is written differently
they've really had a hard time with the
crossword puzzle continuity in this
flick didn't think haha one I finally
discovered something that can crack the
case I'm going to get to the bottom of
this mmm
also what's hilarious about this
revelation about the delivery room being
important is that the movie never goes
back to it's just a reason for the demon
to play more stupid tricks Frenchie ex
machina in one of the ex machina hissed
ex machina 'he's ever mocking it he had
to have literally just gotten here heard
screaming in the delivery's room and
came in like the woodsman from The
Little Red Riding Hood to save the day
the place by all means next time to use
the shotgun
emergency's father well was that if not
an emergency nun demon prefers arts and
crafts to killing if the nuns around
this place have been visions the whole
time then why did they suddenly stop is
it because the two people who don't have
visions walked into the room also
remember the scene earlier when Irene
came in and rudely interrupted the
praying nun the movie was very adamant
about showing her face after Irene left
as if Irene was having visions in some
sort of bizarre cinematic way for the
purpose of an unseen audience the bullet
stopped this paranormal demon on fire in
its tracks which is a sin also why does
Valik stop with all the illusions now
why the previous actions we just saw
changed his MO at all but the demon tend
to our world
it must possess a human soul man why
hasn't it already I'm just saying maybe
do more possessing and less pretending
to be Daniel and the plan might actually
get carried out he wasn't suicide he was
a sacrifice done done and oh yeah not
surprised at all that was so far ahead
of this movie I'm pretty sure I've
already seen the nun three nuns on the
run you're going to love how they tie
Robbie Coltrane and Eric Idle into this
franchise they just tell you where it is
you mean the nuns that have been dead
the whole time yeah I'm sure they said a
lot I receive the vows you have taken by
the way does anyone know a five-letter
word for beetle larva this has been
killing me also movie has time for this
it could have just as easily made Irene
a full-fledged nun from the very
beginning what did this movie gain by
making her a novitiate this whole time
there were no consequences to that yeah
my statue points to an important place
and turns the movie into a discount da
vinci code cliche
I feel like this movie was pitched with
the idea of mixing as above so below
with Indiana Jones but then someone
pointed out that as above so below was
already that same movie and then someone
else said just throw an evil nun into
the mix there's a time for prayer it's
time for Raj force I know it's a time
for action awesome and with the whole 19
minutes left in the movie we need to
search everywhere to find the Gateway
but you don't have to split up do you I
mean that just doesn't seem smart but
welcome to the plot or not no fast none
a while to come and sneak up on a Reno
fast none won't you come won't you come
the nun sets up this perfectly good
scare where a decoy on follows sister
Irene down the hallway then unexpectedly
attacks from another direction but all
it leads to is a bunch of screaming and
maybe a sprained back but little else
and I'm exhausted
so these ghosts just set this up in
advance just on the off chance someone
comes searching around the catacombs
they have to make sure they have some
fun scare tactics ready to go in all
rooms is there a ghost Union it's
frustrating that some of the images in
this would actually be scary in some
other way better movie but the nun has
set up empty scare after empty scare and
this is just filler
but now father Burke you don't have a
lantern to walk around in the dark with
anymore how are you gonna make it
through these catacombs now couldn't God
have stopped the demons without you
giving up your Lantern I know that's
supposed to be scary but honestly this
just feels like a failed Listerine
commercial you see if we knew anything
about Frenchie's character these words
might have some impact but we don't then
this is even more in people also the
movie has a scary as hell none at the
center of it but sure let's just waste
time with sister Irene in demon makeup
instead why would she need a gun
she's a King demon Irene's plan is to
put Jesus's blood in her mouth fake die
when the nun chokes her out then be in a
position to spit blood on her face when
she inevitably checks Irene supposedly
lifeless body not only does Irene leave
a ton to chance here but how does VALIC
not know when a human is dead or not
seriously Marilyn Manson not suing for
lightness rights was a missed
opportunity for all of us sister Irene
somehow survives all this kiss of life
and as a small-town guy who delivers
produce to nuns for a living I just
naturally know this technique because
you pick some things up when you as much
as I do
Frenchie rubs his neck and the movie
reveals that VALIC actually possessed
him while they were battling the demon
but that takes all the Thunder out of
this scene with valack sinking into the
floor and being sealed underneath what
does this scene even mean anymore or
Frenchie got possessed anyway that the
Jesus blood was effective but it has
glaring weakness is also so now you're
just saying that VALIC possessed
Frenchie just before Irene and
supposedly banished him with the blood
of Jesus that is some incredible insight
and makes zero King sense if the demon
possessed Frenchie before it died then
why did Frenchie continue to help out
and give Irene CPR afterwards why did
the demon while it was the nun freaked
out when Irene spat blood on her and
melted into the floor if it was inside
Frenchie and not inside the nut take
Maurice
Pierrot
friends called him Frenchie well this is
a nice callback to the conjuring ed
Warren did not tell the class that his
friends called him Frenchie in that
movie at all an upside-down cross
started to appear from within his body
and in the conjuring this is where their
films grip end it but in the nun the
film continues while the Warrens keep
talking if you're going to make a
callback movie you better get the
details right but what does it matter
this movie sucks anyway hello bitch of
death I said send me these questions
three the other side he see you won't
find another way in
[Music]
it's too late father sister Irene is
lost